thank you everyone for
joining us today we are here to talk to
you guys about
about how we um as consultants to grow
machine learning platforms in
enterprises and
federal specifically
[Music]
a little bit about us i'm hussein sultan
i've been uh i've been doing
data science and deleting data functions
at uh
at numerous enterprises before today i'm
a geometric star
building out the aiu practice uh joining
me here is
ben lindquist ben would you like to
introduce yourself
certainly hussain hi i'm ben lindquist
i have a lot of experience in
highly scaled back-end systems uh
particularly in ad tech
this is the cto of ad juggler where i
built a
transaction processing system for ads
that could do millions of transactions
per second
i've taken that scaling experience and
applied it to
machine learning and ai for the past
four or five years
i've been working on algorithmic trading
evolutionary hyper parameter tuning and
some other fun things like that happy to
be here and talk to y'all today
how about nathan hey guys uh i'm nathan
barber
i have experience in cloud computing
with node.js
and python uh but recently i've been
applying
more attention to mlaps and devops
within
uh this field so nice to be here well
thank you
just so much nathan and ben so a little
bit about
metrostar metro star system is about 21
years old
we are spread across three practice
areas
and we are investing over two million
dollars of a year
in air and d so so speaking about
machine learning platforms
uh what is a machine learning platform
so some of the foundational components
that we have
observed in our consulting practice is
that you start off with the developer
experience
so what that means that means that you
know do you have
um efficient tools to do interactive
computing do you have notebooks do you
have ides
so do you have a great great experience
for the developers
and then on top of the the experience do
you have all the tools and
frameworks and libraries that a
developer or
data scientist might need to do machine
learning experimentation or
or or other analytics tasks you also
uh to get into compute and data um and
in this case compute could be on-prem or
on cloud it could be raspberry pi's
and you need to understand how the
enterprise will be able to deploy
and to consume those computer resources
data is a challenge and a very important
capability that we need is
from from an access perspective can you
just securely access your
data and then how is your data being
stored and up kept
in enterprise you should generally have
large teams or
many teams of data scientists how do you
collaborate across those teams
and in this case your collaboration
could be just sharing of notebooks but
it could also be
uh experiment uh just sharing and
showing results to your stakeholders
serving and monitoring is a very very
important part
how do you take your machine learning
experiments and your machine learning
models to production
into your end to consumer um and
your monitoring is like you know are you
uh
predicting within the bounds that a
machine learning
model was built in
so you're tracking that that's really
growth trajectory or
maturity trajectory we observe about the
four
four phases uh gartner does five uh but
we've
simplified a little bit um so the
foundational bucket uh we
basically think that a lot of folks are
are have analytics or
data science needs that that are medium
to small data or which are bound to
medium and to
small data that means that your data can
comfortably
to fit into your laptop or your
workstation or
or a server the
second bucket in this growth uh
maturity model is the experimentation
stage and in this stage you
are experimenting with perhaps larger
than memory
data you may require some scale
and you are trying to come up with the
with the justifications for
for ai or machine learning use cases
the third bucket is the is the
institutional um and that's where
you might be looking into multi-tenancy
you might be
scaling your like machine learning
platforms across across
multiple types of users or user roles
um you will also be looking at
optimizing your actual costs
um and and the small data science team
to workflows so maybe investing in the
standardized machine learning pipelines
mapping that onto our pi data stack um
you can't it turns out that you can
actually to grow
and traverse this trajectory very well
by just leveraging and just scaling the
pi data core tools that
so you start off with the defacto data
science platform
these things are pandas data frames
these are your jupyter notebooks these
are your
just like you learn um and you know as
you're
experimenting with a larger or uh out of
core data you might be looking at das
as you have multiple data science you
might be looking at multi-tenancy with
jupiter hub uh you might have some of
the best practices at this point with
econo packaging
if you're growing up further on this you
will then be able to
you know perhaps integrate with your
data management platforms
like hadoop through scheme um you have
like das gateway that that
that's like multi-tenancy for das
clusters you may be optimizing
on cuda and gpu workflows
and on the scaled bucket the the example
uh which is a great one is pengio pengio
is the
is it is the machine learning platform
for earth
sciences and it has been sort of to grow
it
grew in a you know just similar to a
trajectory and has
just similar tool sets
in our journey some of the common
challenges that we might
have uh the first one and that's the key
is how do you procure
the open source packages
within the walls and of an enterprise
and like that could be that hey you want
to upstream to mirror your
your open source into a community driven
uh
uh artifact repositories um
to kind of forge a channel on anaconda
uh you might also have some some
licensing and governance part to it as
well that you may want to
white list certain types of licenses
the second challenge is the enterprise
integration and data
this is where you are you are
integrating with the current or existing
technologies that your your enterprise
might have already adopted this could be
as
simple as you know security or auth
integration but it could be more
advanced around if you're building new
services for tracking machine learning
experiments
or creating drivers for data accessing
the quality
and quality reporting
the third challenge is the new scale
right so like as you know machine
learning
is a data hungry process and
and it will consume all the data and you
might need to
uh you know to build more complex models
by using distributed training
techniques you might have hyper
parameter tuning that is a horizontally
scalable process or just optimizing your
your deep learning models and gpus
so diving a little bit deeper into these
challenges
the first one for the open source i'm
just showing you
the reference of the diagram here um you
have some upstream upstream
package providers and you will like to
mirror them into an internal
repositories um this could be your your
artifactory your
wakanda teams um any kind of teams um
and you might have like white lists in
there that you make then you have the
policies and virtual governance aspects
of it that is
dictating how you are building the
packages and
data science environments and then
you're providing those specs into a ci
cd or an automation which a task runner
that is building these these
environments continuously
and making them available for
downstream of downstream users
the second challenge was the enterprise
integration and
jupiter hub is has been like built in a
very like modular manner and it has a
lot of ways to extend in fact
uv panda wrote a blog post uh
last year um where he like listed 99
ways to extend this ecosystem
um so that's that's a good news for us
is real good news for
for enterprises that you can have many
different types of
spawners like you know we're working on
a gpu
spawner for private machines
now the third um is of the new scale
and one of the important part of this is
that you know as you are
you're going from like small data to
like large data um and like just scaling
out to like hypotenuse
infrastructure you want to minimize your
technical cost of migration and i'm just
showing it with your code example on the
local
uh you know this is your sort of local
python code
and then you can make it redistributed
uh by
by using a task bag and like this could
now be
scaled out up next in our demo
ben and nathan will walk us through this
example
and they'll also just show us how we we
integrated a distributed
sorry a of distributed logging mechanism
for for machine learning experimentation
with that i will pass that over to ben
and ben
please to take it away thank you
okay so let's get started
you can see here that we do have a gpu
available on the device
now this next part there's a
project that we created to extend
jupiter hub with an experiment tracking
system
this basically gives you distributed
logging
so that whatever containers pieces of
your
training are running on you can log
actual objects not just text but
binary objects into a central place
so that you can reproduce your
experiments you can track
absolutely everything involved with a
particular experiment
and i'm going to be showing some of how
that works and we are open sourcing this
project
it's called ve2 verify experiment twice
and i usually refer to it as vv
so first i'm gonna i'm gonna set up vv
and it gives me back this run id
so this training i'm doing in this
notebook
is what we call a run now i'm gonna
get a list of all of these pcap files we
put them up in azure blob storage
and 4 400 of them
uh some of them are pretty large
um reading and labeling
and basically building a set of files
that we're going to process we're not
going to process all of them today
just 500 but that's 57 gig of data
now i'm going to log that list of files
to vv
this next part i'm going to connect to
desk we have
das gateway letting us connect
uh letting us spin up ad hoc a compute
cluster
from a kubernetes cluster that's been
set up
in azure and
this is just in an experimental mode so
it's not ssl protected so
uh forgive us for that but i
am going to put in the password
and connect to the gateway um
i guess i'm going to do that twice
now i can start to specify
right in my notebook what kind of
cluster i want
so i'm gonna do two cores
one gig of ram and
this particular container image point
seven that hussein set up for me
i only need one gig of ram even though
the files we're processing
are often larger than a gig because i'm
streaming
uh in each task streaming the file
through the steps of processing
now let's make sure nathan hasn't put a
cluster up that's going to compete with
me
he has not
and now i'm asking for 62 workers so
these are going to be the container i
specified
62 copies of it running in kubernetes
with das on them so that i can spread my
compute across them
and you can see them spinning up here
and
desk gives me a nice
console dashboard
where i can see my cluster we'll come
back to this
now we connect we upload our processing
scripts
and we can kick off the job
and as hussein showed an example of
using a dash bag
that's indeed what we're doing here
and i'm going to launch it now here we
go
and now we can watch this happen
in desk so a little bit about the
task that's actually happening here
each of these tasks is the processing of
one of the pcap files and the way
that we're processing it
is to kick off one
sub-process that streams the file down
from azure blob storage un-g-zipping it
as it streams that goes through a fifo
unix fifo into a tcp dump process
we're using tcp dump to
just get the ascii header information
of all the packets of the file then the
output of the tcp dump process
goes into a third process which
uh uses some code we wrote to
turn the stream of packet headers into
a set of flows flows being conversations
over uh tcp that
that set of flows uh is flow
objects that we created and those flow
objects have code
that lets them output as uh
png images that we can look at
or as numpy arrays that are the same as
the images but that we can put directly
into our
convolutional neural network
also the task that is happening
i'm logging to vv
just to show that we can collect data
from all these workers
for the sake of reproducibility um
i'm doing sampling in these subtasks i'm
not returning all the flows
from a given file i'm sampling them
there
within the subtask and so i have
logging into vv that gives a count of
the flows
and also how long it took
and this uh
this won't take too long to do while
it's it's running
let me just quickly show
the code here um
this tcp dump function
is what's being handed to dask
to run a particular file and
it's then setting up the other processes
collecting the flows
it's telling vv what the run id is
i pass that run id in so that we have a
single key for this entire run
across all of the logging and
then it logs to vv an object the object
is a list
containing the name of the file that was
processed the number of flows
and the time the beautiful thing about
vv is you can log
any object you want it's automatically
going to serialize these
collect them in a central
storage and then give them back to you
which we'll show later
okay we're almost done we're just
waiting for one of the larger files to
complete here
you can see this one has been processing
for a while and that's
that's that uh massive file
it's like 10 gig just to
point out just something that is that is
going on is uh
the script that ben just showed earlier
we are just streaming the pcap files and
like this is why we don't
need a lot of ram uh in our virtual
workers
um so that's a cool optimization of like
you
you're using desk to to like actually
stream the files instead of developing
them all at once
and that does involve some uh
some magic uh don't hate me but i
did write out a python script
from my python script and then execute
it
um okay so we've got we processed 500
pcap files
took three minutes and 46 seconds to go
through that 60 gig
that would have taken a really long time
if we didn't have desk in our compute
cluster
so now let's see what we've got okay we
have
collected 50 000 benign flows
they were not classified as attacks five
infiltration
10 000 ftp brute force
etc and we can look
at some of these uh i'm not going to get
into the visualization style
but you know you can reach out to us if
you're interested
in how we did this these are some of the
flows and what they look like in the
visualization
uh i've now sampled again
down sampled um but done it in a
balanced way
and now here's some random examples of
some of the flows high orbit ion cannon
um okay so now we
do all the numpy stuff and
build a proper set of tensors that we'll
be able to pass in
to our cnn and these are the classes
uh cnn is a has a multi-class
output and so we've got this list of
classes here
which uh we'll get to later
so now we define the architecture
standard we didn't do
anything fancy this is straight out of
examples
so let's go ahead and fit this model
and actually tell you what i'm going to
do i'm going to change this to two
epochs
because the ones we've been doing have
all been one epic and i wanna see
if the accuracy is better that's gonna
give us a good
use case for the vv logging which you'll
see in a bit
so we'll run this through two epochs and
then is this also
running on a gpu yes it is
uh this would be way slower if it
if it wasn't and uh we'd be sitting here
for
you know six seven minutes
watching the little uh arrow
uh so you can see accuracy going up
pretty nicely
and we should go into the second epic
here pretty soon
all right so 92 training accuracy
on the first epic
98 validation accuracy and
and that's on a uh 20 hold out
set
looks like epic 2 is going to get over
99 percent
training accuracy
yup
seems to be topping out
okay so we're and now we're over 99
validation accuracy
so let's see what we've got here we'll
take a look at a confusion matrix
and not too bad
down the center although you can see
we've got one class
i believe that's the infiltrations where
there were only five examples
uh this one's not doing well with five
examples it's
not likely a that there's enough to
train
and b that there's enough in the
validation set to even
test it so in production we would throw
out that class and not attempt to detect
those
i'm now going to log my validation
accuracy
and the confusion matrix itself just the
object
to vv and you can see how easy we've
made this
um now i'm going to save
the model and the
text file describing the classes and i'm
going to shut down my cluster
and with that i will turn
it over to nathan to show us what we can
do
with what we logged to vv
all right so i'm going to show you guys
our voila notebook dashboards
demonstrating ve2
in two distinct use cases and let me go
into what ve-2
and voila are for a second so ve2
is a distributed logging system for
experiment tracking that is integrated
with jupiter hub
whereas voila is basically an extension
an extension to jupyter that allows you
to
cleanly display the results of your
notebook for use in demos or interactive
standalone apps
so the first dashboard we're looking at
will be pulling back the events from a
specific run
logged by ve2 and ben sent me
this specific run id so we just have to
input it into the field
and fetch our run and this will return
to us a pandas data frame
uh containing all the events and logs
that happen during the specific
run i'm going to move on to our second
dashboard which
shows us how we can compare the results
of different runs over a period of time
with confusion matrices
uh we switch over to this and then i'll
let you talk on this one
okay first we're showing just an example
of pulling the project log
from vv when you call vv.setup
to get a run id and log to it you pass a
model id and a project id
easy way to associate models into a
project
and then you can fetch a log of
everything that happened for a given
project
comes back to you as a pandas data frame
and we can see there's a lot of
information logged
this is because we're logging every
worker task
you can log strings floats
or binary objects um so now
let's scroll down and look at a couple
of these confusion matrices
that were generated by the runs
you can see that they are different
uh there's a lot of random sampling in
these runs
even out of the tasks we don't process
the same set of files each time
we don't pull the same flows from each
file each time
so it's very useful to log something
like these confusion matrices
so you can compare across runs and see
if you're getting the same general
performance out of your model
uh each time and indeed while the
numbers here are different um especially
if you look at things that were
misclassified as benign
you see roughly the same order of
of magnitude of misclassification but
they occur
in different places you can see that the
infiltration class as we suspected
in multiple runs is useless
and should be thrown out but you can see
that the other classes
uh and would you scroll up a little uh
nathan yeah that the other classes
we're getting very good results on
uh even across runs just a small
example of how you can use vv
to monitor progress across
all the many runs you do when you're
trying to get a model to work properly
this is all about getting toward
reproducibility
so when you do get it to work right
and then you change some stuff and it
doesn't work anymore
you can just go back to what you had
before vv
in the enterprise version will log the
actual code
from the notebook it will log the user
that ran the code
all kinds of telemetry about that run
and i will turn it back to hussein
awesome thank you again so as you guys
just saw that we've just showed you guys
three examples of how we could extend
our machine learning platform based on
the hub
the first one is that is just desk where
we use
desk and future dash gateway uh to
to to uh just scale out our machine
learning
workflows the just second one was we
extended our
jupiter hub with javala dashboard and
and extensions
and then we also added a custom
experiment tracking
um enterprise just service that was
integrated with the hub